seven years ago one incredible story
blew up the internet when I was 22 I got
involved in the Russian mafia I was a
frat boy on a class trip Mrs Igor here
for your protection he's very dangerous
and we're not to talk to or hang out
with him all I want to do is hang out
with him I did not speak Russian
all I knew how to say was
it was literally the best summer of my
life we robbing this guy yes
three years after those events
the story continues what is wrong with
this shirt
foreign
not today brother not today my dad
showed up you paid money to see my son
tell his made-up story about robbing a
train for the million time it's a true
story it took about two seconds before
he started making me mental look at it
he's a monster
are you the machine ma'am the party's
outside 23 years ago he was told the
only thing my father ever cared about
sorry is this some sort of tick tock
prank I'm about to lose my [__] it's
definitely a prank clearly that's a fake
gun
or not you're coming with me back to
Russia
[Music]
been talking about fast like you're on
speed or something if I'm on speed oh
more drugs
[Applause]
take off that shirt and show those sobs
who you really are now you gotta party
with me
he's the [__] machine
foreign
[Music]
oh my God I'm going to [__] hell I
killed a man well
technically you killed several men